la deuxième partie de ce match à la
cadence de 20 minutes par joueur valeurs
nous avions monsieur hamdouchi avec les
blancs cette fois ce sera monsieur
edouard il jouera avec les blancs
voilà si vous m'entendez lever la main
merci de faire silence pour le début de
cette deuxième partie
donc c'est le parti qui va être
passionnante puisque là un roumain
edward russie nouvelle très belle
performance dans la première manche en
faisant nul face à issia mangouchi avec
les droits et voilà c'est parti
c'est parti à eux quatre pour romain
edouard et bien il change il a choisi
lui aussi une défense sicilienne mais ce
n'est pas de défense juive nikov puisque
c'est le coût de 6 qui a été joué et non
pas le coup nous non pas le coût de 5
donc voilà et si donc ça c'est le la
sicilienne avec le petit centre
le petit centre bonne oreille sicilienne
mais cette fois ci l'aurait je dois
membres et 2 je devais de faire le calme
y compris à l'accueil s'il vous plaît
merci de faire le calme pendant la
partie
alors le nom de cette variante stephen
c'est donc c'est le petit centre un peu
comme ça et c'est la plage fait
schwenningen c'est celle là voilà c'est
pas trop la police n petit centre je
sais pas je connais pas les laisser dans
la dans ce type d sans doute sans doute
sans doute en fou et 3 je crois que ces
descentes donc on ne joue pas aux cinq
parce qu'on garde le contrôle de la
casse des cinq là c'est encore notre
type de oriente tout cas belle
performance de romain edouard superbe
alors ça s'est joué en quelques secondes
la firme toutou sans talent que quand
lui connaissait ce qui est quand même
exceptionnel et un sondage de jouer avec
7,7 force de jeu effectivement
petit rock donc cette fois les deux
joueurs vont jouer un début plutôt
tranquille à 6 à 4 superbes avec rock 90
des deux autres face au petit on empêche
b5 qui est un coup thématiques pour les
noirs et 5 avec l'idée mais en général
les jaune et noir joue quand même v6
souvent voyez le set
le problème est loin c'est qu' ils ont
un centre retenu un peu moins des
spasmes et ils attendent leur heure
parce que ce centre peut se détendre à
tout souvent comme un ressort
il est là prêt et puis les les fous
trouve souvent des passages avec food et
8 pouces et 7 fou bct up se braquent sur
le sur le petit rocker donc attention
ces manoeuvres la bretelle partout tendu
cette première partie moment c'est
vraiment ce match tient ses promesses
pour l'instant oui là les blancs en
général faut un plan avec roy chain et
puis f4 il se sert du duo des pions
alors on met tout d'abord aux achrafiens
ensuite escale f4 et ça on va se servir
de ce duo de pions et eux pour qu'on
joue le roi choquer mais pour pour ne
pas avoir de soucis plus tard si on
s'était diagonale voile ainsi pour pas
se retrouver avec un échec
embêtant plus tard et comme ces
prophylactique comme on l'a vu dans la
première partie celle en cours qui
visiblement ne fait rien mais évite des
problèmes ultérieurs
et puis on va mobiliser le pian le pied
en f1 puis une assurance en fait ça
compte quand on prend une assurance
c'est qu'on prévient les risées quotient
voilà on prévient les risques prend des
précautions ou un prophylactique ça pour
nos jeunes amis prophylactique qui
empêche donc quelque chose lui qui sort
ça dans sa prochaine rédaction gagnera
ce qui peut gagner une bonne note
sans doute mais prophylactique c'est à
une rage de dents au prophylactique
s'éteint et et le f2 et les femmes un
mot qui mérite sa place dans un texte
alors les plaisantins 10 un coup à
profil tactique a profité beaucoup
qu'elle confie tactique
quelquefois je connaissais pas alors la
b6 et si ça c'est ce que je disais donc
on peut pas le louper ça alors on joue
quand même v6 parce que ce fou qui est
bouchée de ce côté là on veut le mettre
et on va le mettre sur la grande
diagonale pour taper sur pied en quatre
pour attaquer le centre hub l'enfer
prescience entre blanc qu'en général les
blancs voient la jouer 4 est comme ça
surtout bessette on a juste le temps de
mettre le fouet trois joyeux et de pas
bloqué puis on est donc comme la
diagonale n est pas accessible la
famille de diagonale dont tu parlais
tout à l'heure la diagonale à 7 juin
n'est pas accessible aux pièces noir
puisqu'il y avait six des bilans des six
mois donc il l'a pas joué ouachin ils
économiseront achat il est pas obligé
toujours un chemin puisque les gones aly
si effectivement existe pas vraiment
puisque maintenant l'option b 6 empêche
la dame dit d'y aller
donc ça a moins de sens de jouer rouach
1 voilà donc faut baisser alors qu'il y
a des belles avoué trop et c'est
immédiat les coûts sont très logique
alors fou et 3 si on l'avait joué faux
et ce trois que le pion f utt encore un
f2 eh bien on aurait bloqué cette
possibilité d'avancer du ballan bmc
c'est à la fois la case ou 5 et il peut
menacer aussi importants puisque le pion
aux 6 est une cible maintenant que le
fou n'est plus ans évite à sa défense
puisque qu'avec des cadres déjà tapent
dessus
alors si on jouait pts 5 ça fait une
double menace alors l'idée de obsèques
ce sera ensuite de jouer g4 g5 et une
attaque de voilà l'idée en fait pression
sur eux si c'est une première chose et
une fois que les normes protégé par
exemple rejoint 5 et bien on peut jouer
j'ai 4 puis j'ai cesse et il apparaît
qu'on a deux gros pions ici qui peuvent
soit poussé angers 6 pour casser ce roi
soit éventuellement même un f6 suivant
les cas pour affaiblir les cases noires
donc
voilà un peu l'idée c'est alors par
contre il est toujours responsable
évidemment d'avancer des pions comme ça
parce que savage élise la défense et des
rois le roi donc il faut savoir qu'il ya
des avantages mais il ya toujours aussi
des inconvénients
alors le dernier coup les des noirs la
dame c7 c'est un coup typiquement
sicilien c'est la souple l'alabama ces
sept on contrôle le cincle exerce une
pression à travers les pieds en sueur
sur le centre et puis elle se positionne
sur la colonne ouverte à colonnes
sicilienne la colonne ouverte
alors voilà tout de suite donc
finalement bien sûr maintenant donc
c'est à dire donc là les noirs s'ils
prennent en main que c'est pas bon du
tout parce qu'on pourrait reprendre du
cavalier avec un gros gros cavaliers
attaquant des elfes ou attaquant espions
des six attaquants la case 17 ça
s'appelle un cavalier kasparov
on peut l'appeler comme ça que les rohff
qui dit qu' un cavalier en f 5 face à un
rock et demi ça vaut un pion à ses
cavaliers un cinquième est toujours un
banc lecavalier quand il est plutôt ce
don vito stable qu'un valet au f5 vous
un gros pions pays bas et dont ils
provoquent ils attaquent des cas il est
très dangereux et si on joue g6v on
affaiblir je cesserai les cases et des
quinze mois donc tant que simple couleur
malhoun on évite ces variantes très
délicate à jouer donc cavalli métro
alors cavaliers b3 il fallait bien
mettre ce cavalier quelque part alors il
aurait pu choisir le joueur d'oud si
avec l'idée g4 et ensuite cavale et g3
verrouiller le pion 1,4 oui mais il a
aussi besoin d'une présence sur sur les
dames sur l'ale d'arrivée de présents
ici en tout cas on sent qu'il a très
très bien préparé ce match
romain edouard il n'a pas l'air du tout
d'avoir de soucis dans les ouvertures
est à noter que la pris deux petites
minutes d'avancé
ça leur cavalier b17 ça y est les très
gros match du champion d'europe 1 dès
peut-être des deux favoris de ce grand
prix 2007 jean douchet avec laurent
frayssinet finaliste 2005 les noirs en
terminer proprement leurs débuts ils ont
leurs quatre pièces mineurs en sortie
sur des cases où elles sont stables les
tours sans lier la dame est sortie le
rock est effectué on ne passe là dans la
phase du milieu de jeu aura noté que le
google 17 a du sens plutôt coquet
nécessite d'abord parce que ça ne bouge
pas le fou déjà c'est mieux que le fou
ne soit pas bouché mais en plus c'est
qu'en valais peut venir ans et 5 pour
attaquer une troisième fois
hop hop le point 4 qui est la faiblesse
centrale eu des blancs qui en même temps
à la fois ce qui protège la case des
cinq ou six qui protège le pion aux
excès même centrale évidemment si on
perd en cour centrale c'est souvent si
ac
c'est pénible si si on le perd
gratuitement donc le cavalier b17 mena
installé en c5 sur une case agréable il
faut parfois c'est souvent à nantes nous
confond avec un envol et au point de vue
physique oui mais il a une ressemblance
6 6 1 en danse dans le visage
mais lors la morphologie kitenge
manhattan ah non on dirait numéro un
mondial actuel qui a gagné le
championnat du monde fis de fidh et de
la fédération internationale dame de il
termine lui aussi son début mais le
positionnement de toutes les pièces les
tours sont liés il faut que les jeunes
joueurs s'est imprégné de sa lé grand
champion aussi respecte les principes
fondamentaux du début
les quatre pièces mineurs sortis la dame
sortie sur une case stable les tours
liés et le rock effectuer la sécurité du
roi le taulier c'est important puisque
ces tours se protègent de l'autre voilà
ils peuvent coulisser sur la première
rangée au gré des besoins
alors la colonne de travail sicilienne
la colonne ces colonnes de travail oui
c'est une colonne sur laquelle on peut
on peut travailler on appuie à travers
les photos pour gagner plus mais oui on
va essayer dans l'air du temps
attaque sur la colonne c'est ouais
tourner un alors l'idéal ce serait
évidemment d'avoir un quai d'avoir un
cavalier en c4 qui pourrait prendre b2
et on gagnerait le cavalier ces trois
oui c'est une combinaison qui se fait
souvent dans la sicilienne calamel un
cavalier ans et caban là il peut pas y
aller bien évidemment il ne peut pas y
aller fort et il faudrait qu'ils passent
par par des six pour y aller mais
malheureusement il ya un pion et si on
avance ses pions le père donc sociaux ne
peuvent accéder à la casse et 4 pour
l'instant peut pas mais on peut aller
sur cette case là plutôt 4,5
ça c'est dans l'air du temps ça tout de
suite
alors notez qu signer blanc arrive à
verrouiller ce centre probablement une
fois verrouillé le centre ils pourront
jouer le plan que tu disais renault g4
g5
oui bien sûr si les îles et sans trop
loin s'il est blanc arrive à chasser le
cavalier de lacazette 6e' domineront la
casa des cinq années pour installer un
lecavalier comme des 8
alors il ya dix thèmes v8 elle et elle
est allée intéressante ça peut être de
jouer dame à 8
bizarrement de mettre la balle dans le
coin pourquoi pour soutenir le fou est
toujours attaquer ça c'était les îles de
ré et i télé lui avait montré ce plan
tranquille dans plusieurs parties il
avait laissé installer un pion ensemble
il a démarré avec alors que qudama 8
voilà en général quand au fond des
batteries comme ça peu des batteries
comme fou ça peut des batteries dame
tour c'est long mais la dame dernière
une tour en général on met toujours la
pièce la plus forte derrière
oui c'est mieux parce que tu es ans on
s'est exposé elle ne peut pas prendre la
première en soutien non parce que là
aussi qu'est devant est censé aller au
charbon
donc qui chamla joue un jeu très
académique est propre et bien léché avec
attaque du pion 4 très beau match de
rome et noir vraiment évidemment
s'attendait pas non plus à ce qu'il fait
en nous qu'ils ne fassent pas un bon
match il fait toujours fait des bons
matches pour un prix de bordeaux ou
ailleurs
alors est-ce qu'il va se lancer avec ses
voilà la question il fait rien de chic
qui avait donc battu laurent frayssinet
en 2005 en demi finale de ce grand prix
et qui par contre s'était incliné en
finale du grand prix d'aix en provence
face à nous-mêmes freyssinet avait pris
un peu sa revanche
donc là c'est si les deux joueurs
arrivent en finale parce que là ils sont
dans les tableaux opposé frais signer en
dessous chics et ils seraient à égalité
de fait la belle - est-ce que la belle
voilà la belle serait label ça serait la
belle sur ces grands prix de parties
rapides
on n'est pas là puisque là il ya quand
même le gros gros écueil on à edwards
qui a l'air fou g5 c'est une autre idée
qui consiste à faire pression sur ces
cavaliers f6 alors pour une double idée
simple sur ces 5 c1
déjà je protège le 4 on voit bien que
puis 1,4 et un problème pour les blancs
donc on a vu l'idée de damas huit
on a vu que l'idée du cavaly c5 donc à
la photo j c je protège avec la dame
tout de suite et en plus le fou peut
s'échanger contre cavaliers m6 qui fait
pression sur leucate donc se foulait
indirectement protéger le 4 et
indépendamment et cloud lecavalier
puisque le jouer cavalier senti le
cavalier veut prendre un à quatre le fou
et c'est tête en l'air voilà c'est pour
ça qu'ils jouent à leur tour huit tours
il laisse pas de pièce en l'air et les
grands joueurs et ne pas avoir les
pièces en l'air non pièce en l'air mais
même la combinaison les petits joueurs
s'étaient déconseillé d'avoir des pièces
en l'air il faut toujours les surveiller
l'adversaire peu sournoise mais c'est ce
qu'on appelle une pièce non protégés
mois l'a défendue par aucune autre pièce
voilà la voyez vous regardez toutes les
pièces se tiennent à garder son cavalier
17 et protégé par le khalife 6
lecavalier 6 est protégé par carrier 17
et par le pion g7 le fou bessette est
protégé par la dame b vite les tours se
protègent le fou est maintenant protégé
par la tour dont tout se tient non mais
c'est pas une aucune pièce n'est pas
être né il ya pas de là rien qui traîne
à noter peut-être une petite surcharge
du chaos les 17
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être pour ça que
romain edouard joue intelligemment joué
dame e3 pensez ce que vous voyez le
cavalier 17 protège aussi le cavalier
donc la petite surcharge jusqu'à vallée
mon poisson c'est pas grave puisqu'elle
fou aussi qui protège la présence de
fuite
c'est à dire que s'il joue faudra henri
cavallier sofo et puissent comprendre
cavaliers on ne sera obligé de prendre
du fou donc deux côtés des deux concédés
la case des cinq romans je disais sur
fouet fuite même sur fuite
oui tout simplement faut prendre
cavalier est sûr qu à l epr en europe
d'un champion de france a et 6 et voilà
donc opticien à la fois la dame protège
le fou donc pareil pour romain il n'aime
pas avoir des pièces en l'air et en même
temps il fait des petites attaques ici
donc voilà il renonce pas exploiter la
case des cinq ans la pression donc par
la boue damas huit plaqués avec le thé a
lancé qu'on avait prévu donc ça c'est
bien dans ma vie de prof pression que
sur la diagonale trois attaques sur le
pied en 1 4 et blum 3 défense et il en
ajoute une quatrième
il joue la torah et revient avec la tour
oui parce que il libère sa dame de la
défense du pion de 80 surprotection un
thème qu'on a vu déjà cet après midi on
surprotège 2.4 ça permet de libérer la
dame est le plus mauvais des défenseurs
donc il faut qu'elle soit pression
augmenter encore un peu et nous une
pièce d'applis est une pièce de plus au
bon vous voyez là la pression sur ceux
qui ont décidément et la défense boum
boum boum et boum ça c'est un autre
jouer quoi qu'est-ce qu'il veut jouer
beaucoup d'attaquants 1
il ya quatre attaquants quatre
défenseurs mais et le problème c'est que
la dame est devant la tour la dame est
devant la cour il prend vraiment ici on
est fou prend forme il ya pas de pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de menace
désarmé devant la tour mais oui mais
cavaliers prendre qu'à va les prendre
comme à l'écran vous prend vous prend
faut prendre tout reprendre et
d'apprendre ça il peut pas prendre un
peu pas ça va tout va bien calculée à
chaque fois en maintenant pression
terrible
donc voilà michel soulage un peu son
camp si les noirs prennent lancé edouard
qui soulage audois pendant quelques
heures jouer aux problèmes 6 on peut pas
prendre le relais parce que il y aurait
d'un prendrait six enfants peu mais
iliad en pro b 6 on peut toujours mais
on il faut calculer après d'un premier
cissé il faudrait se venger sur le pion
aux quatre donc il faut prendre du pied
ans qui semblait fou et on n'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr on est quand même prendre
du cavalier et on donne la case peut
peut-être peut-être quand même prendre
s'y prendre les cavaliers il s'ennuyait
d'un premier à autrans b6 faut calculer
car il prend quatre cavaliers prend 1,4
voilà et le pian des six qui traîne
aussi à la fin il ya le pion ici ce pur
la petite reine
non parce qu'il ya le fondu le voilà ce
thème alors le point rester d'abscon peu
de foi partagée avec les noirs quand
même caballé prend et si les blancs
prennent le pion b6 ont souvent ge sur
le pied en 1 4 est sûr que la vallée
prend vous prend vous prend tout reprend
tout reprend d'un prend et on perd le
pion à 6 mais on peut encore prendre le
pion ces deux jours-là oui c'est bien ça
la rigueur
alors on appelle ça l'escaladé prise
c'est à dire il y à une succession de
quatre cinq six prises et l'escaladé le
sens et quelques artistes qui font que
prendre du cavalier qui est grande plus
actif que de prendre du fou et du pion
qui semble pas possible
voilà en option serait une erreur alors
il va il va calculer tout c'est toutes
ces prises parce que c'est jusqu'au bout
et voir ce qui se passe à la fin alors
doucement faut calculer toutes les
presses à rien oublié il faut y aller ou
intermédiaire est sûr il peut y avoir
une surprise
brillamment travers les prises et
apprises et surprise un temps si là il
va peut-être prendre son temps et janola
ici parce que il ya deux options qui
s'offrent à lui qui sont pas du tout
pareil fou prend qui est tranquille mais
qui laisse le pion des 600 défense et
surtout qui livre la case on comprend ça
c'est pas bon pourquoi parce qu'on voit
bien que ça casse la défense du roi
voyez bien que tout ça c'est pas c'est
pas joli un leroy avoir beaucoup de
malades défendu et c'est très passif
donc il faut prendre soin vous prend
mais il faut prendre cavaliers des cinq
et il faut donner le foulée 5 parce
qu'on attaque des six décès en attaque b
6 ans oui bon c'est pas grave on peut
faire vous prend et puis on prend deux
caches la finaliste des citoyens oui
c'est pas gênant oui mais cavale et
prend ou fou prend c'est pas pareil
ce soutien va les prend oui c'est vrai
que j'ai lu c'est vrai qu'à plus la tour
en d1 pour pour reprendre une pièce il
faut toujours prendre une pièce dans ce
type de circonstances quand on est allé
un cavalier sur la classe des cinq
réfléchi et que l'adversaire reprend
laurent blanc d'une pièce est pas
champion puisse passer la faiblesse
j'aime peut aussi se dire ah bon mais
qu'il faut peut-être pas prendre de
risque non plus parce que s'il perd
cette partie c'est fini il n'est quand
même pas venu à bordeaux pour faire les
figurants
c'est un moment important c'est clair
donc il a pris du cavaliere cavaliers
prend m6 et j'y vois là et pour lutter
pour la casse des cinq très beau joueur
suit cham qui avait donné une simultanée
à ambès non enfin mais ça on voyage
total en baisse voyez c'était pour le
place d'armes belge voudrait au festival
du même nom à saint loubès voilà oui
simultanée organisé par notre ami
jean-luc feit jean-luc feit qui est
présent aujourd'hui qui est instituteur
directeur d'école
notamment qui enseigne les aussi des
échecs à aux écoliers quand même et bien
sûr et qui suit ce grand prix depuis sa
création avec beaucoup d'intérêt qu'on
salue ici j'en ai fait quand amis de
notre arbitre patrick besse là bas c'est
en et camarades de cercle et sanaa le
mettrai jamais en tiff très très
attentif et on salue aussi notre ami
julien favarel voilà alors comme prend
mais si beau et si la fed va y établit
les cavaliers on est en plein dans la
variante et se lance dans l'histoire
voilà on salue aussi les filles là haut
séverine et séverine séverine bennama et
son ami séverine qui font la régie pour
des bonal tv qui enregistre ses matches
et en vidéo pour dit on à tv l'émission
des échecs sur internet alors qu'ils
avaient plus loin que l'autre kiki à la
massue récents dans l'autre qui qui va
sortir la variante de faire alors voilà
que des cinq le coût qui est considéré
comme libératoire quand on ne peut jouer
le coup des cinq dans les dents les
siennes il n'a pas voulu prendre en
quatre il fait la libération ici c'est
un peu comme celle inverse de ce qu'a
fait roman noir dans la partie
précédente
c'est lui qui avait cette réflexion oui
donc là c'est un sacrifice de pions
puisque on reprend pas le pion au 4 mai
on joue le coup effectivement libérateur
des cinq pour exploser le sens et puis
surtout en menace des caresses tsonga
plein chose malhonnête mais les blancs
peuvent prendre monde et 5
oui comme le coup logique un oui qu'est
ce qui se passe quand même bizarre
qu'est ce qui se passe sur comprenait 5
mai il y aura les prisons des cinq puis
la présence et de et la tour se
retrouvera ses 2 / sur la seconde ce qui
est toujours intéressant d'avoir une
tour en seconde
voilà alors on salue aussi profité pour
saluer françois merlet président du
comité départemental d'échecs de gironde
qui a fait un énorme travail cette année
pour l'organisation de ce grand prix qui
s'est occupé notamment de la venue des
jeunes invités par le conseil général en
partie et aussi tout le travail qu'il a
fait pour la communication de autour de
cet événement cette année grand tournoi
leucate prendre des 5 c'est embêtant
parce qu'il ya le pion aux scènes qui
ont pris la ville charles a tout calculé
ce qui sépare un peu emballé avec son
coude et simple il a huit minutes 40 89
minutes
et bien il semblerait que dans ce match
romain edouard lui pose de vrais
problèmes
il a pris part à la position des biens
centraux et éclat la paix ensemble en
difficulté quand même donc on va avoir
un jeu de pièces là qui vont convenir
aux jeunes et loire qui n'ont pas les
moyens de pression quand même parce que
pions des unions s'inquiète emprise la
tour je sais pas je sais pas ce qu'il a
voulu faire avec son coude et celle là
je ne vois pas trop en plus les noirs
qu'est ce qui peut faire cavalier prend
semble pas très très bon puisque à six
attaques la dame quand même oui d'accord
donc réussi si monaco rend donc l'idée
c'est que sur cavale et prend ses
attaques la dame donc ça forcerait
quasiment cavalerie cavaliers prend fou
prend il faut prendre la sopref 3 donc
il faut prendre
ouais la dame prend en d5 et protège le
pion oui et tu es pion à cissé est mort
mais le pion séduit confiance et de
violence et 2 donc il ya des choses
alors qu est-ce qu à calculer exactement
hicham on sait pas mais là ils réfléchi
parce qu'évidemment s'il se trompe s'il
a oublié un truc où que ce soit et qui
perd cette partie aïe aïe aïe aïe c'est
quand même le tournoi
qui s'envolent alors faut b4 et romain
edouard qui file en demi finale fauvez 4
et oui cette partie est décisive après
la première partie nul une victoire et
c'est fini seule une partie nulle
permettrait de passer en prolongation et
danser les matches couperets et un
mathieu au rasoir
ouais ça coupe les têtes immédiatement
les quatre en william donc il a joué ni
cavalli prendre des cinq ni quoi que ce
soit d'autre au fond mais qu'a donc
l'idée de fouler 4 évidemment il fait
pression sur le cavalier c3 qui protège
des 5 intéressant et en même temps la
tour 8 protège le pion aux cinq attaques
et par là tout rôle a donc cessé ils
badass au passage de jouer faut prendre
ces 3d prendre part à son cou un foulard
d'un coup malin et menace donc de
d'avoir dû contre jeu sur les pions
blancs et éparpillé et casser la
structure des papillons blancs
il faut réfléchir et il faut pas se
laisser prendre à l'essai fallait
trouver sa voie bien sûr il faut pas se
laisser prendre en c3 et le cavalier
cloud est alors comment faire très joli
coup que jamais j'attaque le cas et ses
trois défenseurs de d5 je protège ou
cinq donc je menace de récupérer des 5
avec l' avantage voilà très joli très
bien mais je connais aussi d'éparpiller
d'éclater les pions en effet tous les
libyens sur le sol elle damas des blancs
vraiment superbe celui de sharon bush y
ait fait un beau match face à la pizza
francisco vallejo l'an dernier oui hélas
il est attendu mais veut pas beaucoup de
pas beaucoup à laurent frayssinet
vérifier annulé lui mais c'est vrai
qu'il fait toujours des par contre très
très belle partie voilà un beau jeu de
pièces pour pour les pions sacrifier
qu'il espère récupérer joue dynamique et
si un jour ce joueur dynamique
oui pour les styles deux pions de moi
mais c'est que provisoire il va au moins
récupérer 1
on va récupérer ailleurs et que les
autres pions reste agi grosse grosse
pression sur la colonne ici avec
maintenant le cavalier qu'étant prix
évidemment s'il est noir il va prendre
ses trois co2 ou me faut deux ans lève
l'attaquent
ah oui malheur l'idée à huy très joli
coup à ce que hicham a prévu ce coup là
ça c'est pas souvent
oui il faut sortir la pas mal pour le
sacrifice de de qualité tout reprend c3
c3 c3 il peut jouer puisque si on prend
un coup d'oeil à face s'arrête pas ça
n'arrête pas maintenant c'est la dame
qui est attaqué c'est coup sur coup un
dans cette partie
donc pour les jeunes joueurs à quintin
vous attaquent une pièce mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé de la sortir vous
pouvez aussi attaqué une pièce plus
importante de votre adversaire
tableau 3 alors maintenant il peut
prendre ces 3 et sur foot pro tour c'est
pas grave on en récupère la tour ici oui
donc il va sans doute faire ça
d'ailleurs hicham et à la fin il va
gober le pion des 5
donc là il va se jouer maintenant je
pense que on va plus tellement avoir de
cette triste réalité cas c'est un ami
peut il peut aussi s'il peut aussi
j'étais en train de me dire renault est
tout simplement reculé à tour par
exemple ensuite oui pour garder ça pour
garder la pression sur ces trois sa tour
présente mais bon passons sur ces trois
stations lecture des 5 semble condamné
c'est sûr et comme ça si lecavalier
bouge ccl2 qui tombe donc oui peut-être
il peut préserver sa tour il veut
préserver la tour je pense qu'il va
jouer tour ces 8es
je crois pas trop à faux prince et 3
parce que au final les blancs resterait
comme si en plus il me semble qu'en ces
trois faucons tour faut prendre tour
tout reprend en fou fou prendre des cinq
là imaginant fou voilà pour ces bidons
j'aimerais vous voyez recul sa tour la
raison est bien qu elle qu à l égard de
ces options est là et gardent les
options qu'ils continuent à faire
pression sur le cavalier et le pion des
cinq qui est perdu on voit déjà il est
attaqué et le défenseur est attaqué il
ya comme défenseur déjà donc ça suffit
pas en plus il est attaqué si le pion en
bougeant des six pour éviter d'être pris
c'est le pion de g2 qui tombe ce qui est
pire parce que c'est un pion quand même
juste à côté du roi actions de défense
donc et cette batterie a l'air très
forte d'ailleurs maintenant et oui oui
renault parce que si ceux qui ont des
cinq tombes
il ya des problèmes sur les problèmes
sur le sol diagonale à leur tour la
protection des cinq mais c'est pas
vraiment une protection qui tient la
route puisque [ __ ] en c3 va venir et
on ne peut pas empêcher faut prendre les
scènes puisque surtout reprend fou
évidemment la dame reprendre et et y'a
plus rien pour les blancs révélions
c'est lorsqu'il faut sans doute
maintenant oui et je voyais faute à ces
points et positionne l1 ce qui est en
train de se passer là qu'est ce qu'il
est lente et un allié ces cinq caisses
qui l'a inventé qu'elle aille et c5 pas
mal alors l'idée simple qui avait laissé
sa cavale et prendre cavaliers vous
prend et la dame est bardé bien sûr le
cavalier ne peut pas être pris un pas
prendre le cavaly parce que la dame
serait cloué c'est à dire que ne peut
pas bouger puisque derrière le roi
serait en échec du fou donc on peut pas
prendre ce cavalier or la menace des
noirs restent complètement intacte et
même sa grave puisque les noirs
maintenant menaces y compris de prendre
en b3 donc le fameux conte roi charles
le fameux coup prophylactique harry qui
est toujours utile je prends de b3g pas
si c'est bien ce que sookie aller décès
il vient de se préserver la paire de
faux voilà il se dit je vais pour pas
pris qui ont des seins j'ai pas récupéré
manquions menaces blanche non c'est fou
ces 4 donc il va être obligé de prendre
7 points et finalement il a rétabli la
chaîne des pions blancs
il a rétabli à fiona puis en blanc mais
les pions on reste faible les pieds en
b2 et b3 sens pas si c'est quand même je
sortais je sais pas s'il qualifie 3
tenez la dragée haute au km 7 donc ça y
est récupère ce qu'a choisi cham et
récupère sans son matériel
vraiment je pas très convaincu il fait
pression sur attention pression sur g21
la menace ont surgi de et est sûr b3 1
il attaque aussi pétrole a donc et il
récupère son matériel récupère son
matériel
il ya une double menace
ralala billion double mode s pourrait
combler avec matériel quand m costaud
oui et donc ensuite bien il aura la
meilleure structure
alors attention en vidant la meilleure
structure il aura quatre contre trois
sur les droits et ce pion isolé c'est
qu'ils seraient une cible pour pour pour
la finale je rappelle injuste je pense
que les arbitres patrick besse nous
entend simplement à la fin de la partie
demandé aux joueurs de ne pas toucher
aux pièces au cas où la partie s'achève
façon on est le temps donc là on est en
dessous des 5 minutes on est en dessous
des 5 minutes mais c'est une
superposition alléger une combinaison
très long oui herbe
il a bien jugé l'histoire il ay la vue
qui récupère et qui récupère et c
cc pian et en sortir il a la meilleure
structure donc il faut absolument que le
roumain edward fasse quelque chose et
tout de suite il trouve et il trouve y
met le doigt où ça c'est aussi sa femme
comme ça
oui même gardé même fou prend j'ai deux
bonnes amies oui oui oui
renault alors vous promet 3 imaginons la
menace un coup les blancs regarder
évidemment g5 menace maths et si j'ai
six matches si ces menaces matin et
c'est le match de l'oly oui c'est le nom
donné à cette cette figure son projet de
roger 1
qu'est ce qui se passe mais il a joué
tout à la fois maintenant g7
oui mais il vient de jouer pour ces six
pour pour menacer pour problème 6 et ne
craignons pas d'objets 5 et 7 tout
redevienne un oui c'est au tour de
vienne puissantes comme g3 il va prendre
les six noms ah oui il peut prendre les
six tout simplement sur d'objets 3.6 et
ensuite il jouera tout rejet 6 par
exemple ensuite il aura des menaces le
leur le roi blanc vient de se faire un
peu les habiller la g6
on pourrait jouer fou g4 est suracheté
et roumanie doit avant oui et oui prend
alors attention tout ce qui se passe en
france et trois échecs de la dame
fouilles 3 il s'est tu reprends fo prend
en tout on prend tour et il récupère et
il garde ses lauriers
hier le pion avec une position de finale
finale deux tours
alors alors finale de démo ici way mais
c'est une façon tout nul mais bien sûr
surtout comme ça dd finale avec des des
faiblesses des cibles la simplification
c'est une très très belle partie les
joueurs aimeraient alors là tu le coût
normal ce droit si ça serait de joutes
au v8 cette partie va va s'acheminer
sans doute vers 17 heures une nuit
l'origine cette partie-là s'acheminer
vers une nulle et ce qui était très
intéressant de voir dans cette partie
c'est le le coup f6 cajou et romain
edouard au moment où il a au moment où
ils élèvent web où il a joué pour
perturber la structure noire sinon il
allait subir une finale désagréable
superbe
c'est vraiment super voilà c'est nul il
choisit de faire nul puisque là les
noirs on va juste laisser les pièces en
place les noirs menace simplement vont
prendre le pion de dire à trouver jolie
comtois savent facilement l'a pas gagné
la tendance se mettra derrière leur pas
entrer dans les détails parce qu'il faut
y passer désormais tout simplement la
tour noire se mettra derrière le pierre
blanche et le roi reste le g7 voilà mal
à enchaîner sur les beats vous ne sortez
pas l'interlude aura avec les noirs pour
les plis de départ voilà l'interlude est
très court on va enchaîner avec les
départage donc très beau match que nous
a offert là que nous ont offert les deux
joueurs romain edouard et hicham
hamdouchi
faut remettre les pièces en place alors
bon peut-être un détail important c'est
que hicham avait toujours la vence
autant donc il a toujours eu une minute
ou plus d' avance sur son adversaire
donc peut-être que ça va peser dans ce
blitz donc julien kit aller plus vite
que l'éclair a déjà superbement me
l'échiquier résumant l'état
donc on a pu apprécier toutes les
qualités de ce jeune romain edouard
hubert beau match que nous offrons
romain edouard décidément on n'est pas
champion d'europe à 16 ans pour rien il
tient la dragée haute un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde dans ce charmant bouchy
noël sicilienne mais être extrêmement
agressive et la fameuse un camille la
fameuse variante perez où il ya souvent
un sacrifice de pièces ouais ouais mon
insurgés 6 ou la g6 souvent les noms de
lait blanc hells lecavalier ont prise
c'est peut-être ce que va faire richard
voilà extrêmement agressif
ah non il choisit la variante avec h5
challandes bochy a l'intention remet
dois je le sais joue beaucoup beaucoup
de blitz sur internet
c'est le coût qui aimait jouer karpov
dans cette position parce que karpov a
joué ce début ça pourrait ne pas évoquer
style de karpov des cours avec g4 et
tout ça mais et karpov a joué plusieurs
parties intéressantes avec vous j'ai
c'est que cette variante avec un prof à
tout bruit
oui c'est un joueur universel faut
prendre que font les noirs y reprennent
alors avec qu'est-ce qui reprennent avec
le pion ou avec la dame
je pense qu'il va reprendre avec le pire
non la brique la dame
eh bien je me suis trompé bien avec la
dame
cavalli ou trois d'accord mon idée c'est
un peu comme la cheville nicolas oui
tout de suite elle a tout de suite la
case des cinq ans forçant la dame n'en
revenions des huit quasiment puisqu'il y
aurait menace d'une fourchette ici tout
aura d'ailleurs la dame est revenue tout
de suite même sans attendre cavaliers
des cinq cas les scènes qui menace une
fourchette 3 tours ici mais il est
anticipé que twitter hicham il n'a même
pas attendu que les blanches qu'il y ait
des cinq qui joue tout de suite là
encore on m'a edwards a tout de suite
joué deux variantes nerveuse active à ça
pour être honnête c'est clair très beau
match dont la superbe vraiment superbe
trois superbes y tient la dragée haute à
gauche il a réussi c'est de la partie
précédente était extrêmement tactique
ouais on a vu comme ça c'est ouvert d'un
coup comme la position des charmants
douchy s'est ouverte avec toutes les
possibilités qui avait envoyé les
personnels est mort la faim prend
cavalli et 6 donc hop fondement de ces
huit dames détroit donc ça ça va vite
les pieds alors jour pareil voyage jour
dominé la case des 5 voilà on sort aussi
léon sur les pièces on va rappeler quand
même les fondamentaux on a sorti des
pièces maintenant sorti la dame on veut
préparer sans doute le grand roque avec
une position de pièces libre facile
active la tour va venir ici sur la case
des alliages les tourments être liés aux
voyages des tours et on recoupe pas
évidemment de ce petit côté puisque la
loi bien qu'il manque un pion pour
protéger le droit donc aux robes de
l'autre côté il va très certainement
faire le grand roque roumain edward
zwick traître je pense que tout de suite
il va le faire mais oui il faut le faire
tout de suite parce que cavalier 4 est
dans l'air on va peut-être même le coup
droit bien pour protéger le pion à 2
quand même voilà il y avait qu à l
épreuve 4 qui planait avec dame prend
tout reprend ses 3 wii avait des menaces
suivies d'un sacrifice en c3 avec la
dame ou la voilà il le foyer c'est le
sacrifice thématique de 2
au delà de la sicilienne bien sûr dans
ce type d'action et font tous il faut
tout de suite affaiblir le roi valider
oui sacrifice de qualité mais on a le
fou noir
alors si les blancs les prix de la dame
on a le faux loin aurait changé les
dames c'est ça ben non on en reste
quatre n'aurait pris 1 à 4 oui on aurait
changé d'âme je suis pris un à quatre
attaquants c'est royal de on aurait eu
au moins deux pions plus les pions
faible
les pionniers de la réserve au sol et
oui belle compensation
donc c'est pas ici c'est un classique
tous les tous les pays je sais pas si
j'aurais tenté ce genre de truc je
connais pas bien ce genre de position et
tous les ans c'est quand même certifie
de tous contre pied ce mineur java et/ou
les mais on voit bien que la
compensation c'est que ses pions sont
éclatés ça c'est sûr c'est que tous les
joueurs de sicilienne sont prêts à
donner la tour sur le cavalier ces trois
partis quand ils en leur fout le cafard
vivant la dame va probablement prendre
en a deux mais c'est plus que probable
puis avoir d'autres types de menaces
avril à la cinq puis la tour la tour peu
arrivent à l'âge 3 aussi sortir en a
trois la tour par imane h3 navale à toi
et bien sûr empêche le pion avancé que
le cavalier pardon tout le cavalier ou 3
ris maintenant il dit louant un jeu van
damme c4 il protège aussi le pion à 2 il
a joué tout de suite un rom edwards de
connaître ça sur le bout des doigts
17 alors qu'une femme semble prendre un
peu plus de temps
assez hot d'artprice est un problème
c'est oui bien sûr si je préfère fouet
cette caisse qui se passe qu'est les
câbles et 5
oui attention d'en prendre cette menace
que font les noirs ça semble être une
erreur là de hicham secoue le roi 17 là
oui c'était pas très heureux après tout
ça c'était peur du tout quelque chose il
faut jouer d'amd 8 pour défendre mais
c'était il abandonné il a abandonné
alors je suppose - alors il attend faut
pas bouger les pièces on va pas bouger
les pièces et sur d'amd 8,6 à tout
reprendre dès 6 h 6 pas regarder ce qui
se passe sur ma vitre nous explique si
le seul coup qui est sérieux qui déforme
qui défendent cette c'est d'amener vite
et sur quoi il ya tout reprendre des six
donc c'est une gaffe il a fait savoir le
blanc le jeu avant la gaffe et il a joué
roi 17 le seul coup pour des plantes
s'adapter vite sur quoi il ya tout
reprend des six qui gagne la dame qui
explose la position louis roy prend et
ensuite laissé filer tour des uns et la
dame est perdus c'est fini alors on va
donc chargé
la partie suivante voilà en bauchi alors
oui bon c'est parti avant même qu'on l'a
c'est reparti c'est parti très vite
ces partis avant phase donc la jeunesse
et le jeu tactique actifs ça a joué très
très vite on se retrouve dans une chaise
nikov quasiment type de type classique
donc la même que tout à l'heure mais un
peu différente dire que les noirs n'ont
pas joué
la variante
classique avec avec le g5 + blanc qu'est
ce qui se passe et les blancs et les
blancs qui jouait faut que j'essaie dans
la voiture classique qu'ils ont joué
tout à l'heure alors bien sûr
edouard une petite nul lui suffit pour
éliminer et chammam de chez cavalli des
4 il remet edwards pourrait créer la
grande surprise de ce premier tour du
grand prix de bordeaux dans ce quart de
finale puisqu'ils mènent face à charles
j s'ils arrivent à faire au moins un
parti duel avec les noirs dans cette
partie hesham doit gagner et liszt et là
c'est vrai qu'on voit que les jeunes en
fait quand même de l'énergie à revendre
et beaucoup l'énergie que ça joue
beaucoup même aux échecs énergie et peur
de rien c'est à dire comme ça on prêt à
jouer des variantes aiguë oui mais c'est
à dire qu'ils ont rien à perdre et
épuisant fois dans leur dard leur foi
stark force tactique et des cuiseurs
favoris donc il faut son va tout il
prend un maximum de risques et c'est sûr
qu'il faille lui c'est plus difficile il
a tout à perdre il n'est pas encore
éliminé hicham hamdouchi mme alors c'est
quand même un chien c'est encore pour
l'instant la surprise de ce quart de
finale de ces quarts de finale de ces
quatre premiers quarts de finale pour
l'instant ce serait la victoire
l'élimination du shanxi la victoire de
romain edouard mais bon c'est pas fait
maintenant remet devoir de se dire je
peux me qualifier ça peut aussi lui
jouer des tours il peut prendre
confiance un peu trop ouais il a déjà
hélas il a déjà gagnante et minutes a
peur de gagner ça existe aussi un nom
j'ai trois oui et bien sûr mais non mais
je peux te dire que c'est elle gagné le
petit hacker cavalli c'est cette niche à
prendre réussisse certainement il va
prendre six il va prendre le faux 6 et
jouer fourrage 3 1 sans doute riche âme
il est venu il est venu avec l'idée de
taper sur le pion de 6 il aimait la
place le fait voilà il le fait en live
donc c'est facile
[Musique]
quand il faut défendre il faudrait
prendre 6 dames 7,7 petit rock sayeda
psion aussi davantage blanc c'est un
autre cavalier fou contre les cavaliers
puis un doublé mais colonnes f
alors que l'on est ouverte à tous même
si c'est intéressant ça protège au 6 mai
le problème c'est comment donner du jeu
à ce cavalier ou est ce qu'il va pouvoir
3 est logique
la position au smi le fou donc il ya
c'est le défenseur pour pour le rock là
pour le petit rock un peu sur 17 et le
problème des noirs c'est cette cette
pièce ce cavalier c6 qui va pas pouvoir
participer rapidement ce cadre il a en
projet et oui pour l'instant il n'a pas
de gaz installées oui comment le faire
jouer sauf que là il tape sur rien il
n'y a pas de case c'est à dire que
regarder ne peut pas les en dés 8
il peut pas aller en 7 il peut pas aller
en cinq donc des cartes à cause du pion
donc qui va jouer et il va essayer de
forcer des quatre pour pouvoir trouver
une case au cavalier attention tour d un
don qui va jouer des quatre plans je
n'ai pas trop pu si on est noir 1 j'aime
pas trop la position des noirs il faut
qu'ils jouent des quatre et qui t'a
donné speer en d3 plus tard alors
récupéré la case des quatre pour le
cavalier nous c'est fou prend 2,6 et sur
dame prend tout simplement plus en
confiance dans fourchette avec cavalli
v2 petite fourchette grosse fourche est
oui qu'est ce qui se passe pour nous là
qui on prend 1,4
donc voici encore très rares des pions
de replay centraux ouais des pions
replay donc ces départs ne propose pas
j'ai donc cédé faiblesse énorme on voit
pas souvent sa méthode qui sont là mais
bon
donc ils sont là ils peuvent toujours
jouer 3 ha oui il fait vaillant le clan
adverse et pourront jouer 3 sans doute
et pourant dame c4 lors d'annoncés
captait l'idée c'est de libérer puis on
met quatre pour jouer b4 b5 attaqué ce
qu'a laissé six faut toujours empêcher
ces cavaliers de jouer c'est ce qui est
le cas tant que le puits en c3 est là le
cavalier et contrôler la le pion enlève
des cases aux cavaliers les casses b4 et
des quatre que je montre ici avec les
flèches voilà à ce pion ici empêche le
cavalier de venir sur ces cases là donc
c'est un pion qui domine un peu le
cavalier le fou ici très bien placé il
tape sur la grosse faiblesse le 6 des
noirs voile et ses pions qui peuvent pas
se protéger les uns les autres sont des
cibles évidentes il suffit de les
attaquer pour qu'il soit prenable aussi
le ku'damm c4 à la clôture 4 et charges
des échanges des tout autour mais il
faut faire quelque chose pour pour ce
pied ont agi alors qu'on peut rien
d'entamer talent leur avantage blanc
rien à dire ces avantages blanc ou la
dame oui alors il schaming pas peur de
tout reprend f2 la dame protège à tour
mais fou prend 2,6 la dame est attaqué
et on gagne la qualité ici la dame est
flou et donc il faudrait prendre le fou
et dans ce cas là la tour ne serait plus
défendu dans confort irois prendre tous
renvoyés donc ces combinaisons tactiques
petit défense et indirects qui l'a pas
peur cela me laisse les noirs mais non
ils tombent pas dans le piège romain
edouard évidemment le gamin et quand
même donc romain edouard un retard au
temps légèrement en prenant alors deux
minutes et rosset contre 1048
s'établissent donc ça va ça va
s'accélérer à macérer dans machete damev
oui comme ça à la sa manoeuvre
maintenant les menaces pour preuve deux
noms qui le défend oui parce que le foot
est revenue puis le fouetter revenus de
menacer plus fou prend 1,6
donc il défend f2 et du rock et du coup
c'est tout un travail et travailler au
pays de trouver une belle case pour le
cavalier c'est la lame attention tour 17
moi j'aime pas du tout ça alors j'aime
pas ça j'aime pas ça du tout j'aime pas
du tout cette ce qui se passe là voilà
oui mais d'abord il envoie la voix le
roi cet envoi le voit un petit peu aux
frais tour d'essai dès lors laisser cet
élément le pion à c'est aussi bon gros
avantage blanc hicham pour égaliser dans
cette partie et 43 s'est vite x 4 échecs
alors on est en échec le foot très bien
placé voilà que les 2,5 g 4 non ça
marche pas parce qu'il ya tout rejet 6
in extremis clou le pion et tournoi là
on prend des 17 lots voilà ça y est gros
avantage pour hicham hamdouchi qui
revient dans le match alors en cas
d'égalité au bout de ce deuxième but on
assisterait à un blitz mort subite
oui ce qui serait intéressant puisque là
il y aurait donc tirage au sort et cinq
minutes aux blancs contre quatre au noir
donc avantage ou blanc mais on sait que
sa pièce apprend à cette voie là
c'est horrible donc là il jamais archi
gagnant oui oui là il a une elle à la
faille et la vend ses pions il a une
elle d' avance en avant il a une elle d'
avance les noirs ennuyant dans leurs
attendus
c'est horrible tous rêvent cette sas et
le coup qui fait très mal il peut faire
tout reprend
pas sûr oui il faut pas qu'un fait tuer
la quête perpétuelle quête perpétuelle
donc il est à peine perpétuelle c'est à
dire un échec perpétuelle ouais il était
inapte à paris là il a dû voir qui est
caché son roi en acheter joly pense
qu'il va cacher abandonné là au manoir
peut-être un oui après un bond à tout
moment il faut prendre
c'est très chaud donc là ils ferment du
shit en passe de d'équilibré ce match de
revenir dans le match
oui va essayer de chercher les chèques
sont habituelles mais le roi ballet
s'abriter le roi va aller sans doute non
il fait d'abord f3 oui il fait d'abord f
travail quand soleil en est l'heureux
bien sûr mais bien sûr voilà il revient
à f2 il y avait des filles c'est fini
voilà voilà ça y est voilà ça c'est fini
maintenant l'échangé provost regardez
donc on va expliquer rapidement les
blancs maintenant comprendre la tour tu
apprends en échange des dames et ensuite
c'est toute la différence dans le but de
blesser 3 billion et pendant ce temps le
roi valser les arrêter le rappeur ont
fait d'armé au maroc la belle
démonstration du grand maître là qui
nous feront l'honneur jouer avec ses
pièces active contre ce cavalier qui
n'avait pas d'avenir
pendant que tu as promis du comac
choisissez ab bombe h
on va dépasser le sens l'ouïe beau match
un beau match au finish le grand maître
n'allait pas se laisser marcher dessus
comme ça on pouvait jouer sur nos
terrains du chic est passé très près
delà de la défaite dans ce match et
ouais mais là il a il a montré sa force
à la dans cette partie superbe match
extrêmement tendu
on va pas perdre de temps pour la suite
ces écoutes aux commentaires
la perte de temps ça va tout de suite
enchaîné alors on sait pas encore quel
est le tirage au sort
quelle partie belle partie belle partie
belle démonstration de diamal quel match
quel match de ma superbe match voilà les
deux joueurs voiliers qui sont tendus
évidemment parce que là ça va se jouer à
très peu sur une seule partie
est ce que le tirage au sort a été et
sera mal est fait peut-être julien tu
peux me signaler n'ont pas encore un
tirage au sort n'a pas été fait alors
n'oubliez pas qu'il va y avoir cinq
minutes pour 1,4 pour l'autre c'est ça
ou 6 5 c'est en quoi les obligations ça
y est blanc et 4 noir voilà c'est 5,4
avec obligation de gagner pour celui qui
à la minute de plus la nullité alors
assure le gain du match à celui qui à la
minute de moins alors qu'est la décision
à prendre est ce qu'on prend la minute
où est-ce qu'on généralise joueurs
choisissent quand même d'abord les noirs
et la minute de moins de moins la minute
de moins 20 minutes de moins mais avec
la nul ils s'en sortent donc très
important d'avoir le choix
dans cet îlot de ce qui se passe
monsieur les blancs pour mon mari doit
gagner
tirage au sort a pris une décision pour
vous repérer et julien si tu peux dire à
l'arbitré à mettre les blancs qu'il faut
qu'on attende qu'on soit dans les bras
une minute de plus de temps de réflexion
voilà très bien donc c'est edouard
contre 32,6 voilà donc non le temps est
pas bon on n'est pas bon on n'est pas
vrai ça y est c'est parti je fais partie
c'est parti et toujours la querelle
sicilienne voilà donc voyez qu'il ya
quatre minutes
enfin donc 53 minutes 50 pour les noirs
a par contre on n'a pas le temps on a
raté le temps où malheureusement à wigan
a démarré avant que ça soit envoyé là de
l'otan n'était pas en route sur les
richesses et paca les chiffres à messac
ça compte quand même le temps si si
c'est bon oui mais quand même ça sûr il
n'a pas pour pas pour l'autre c'est la
marche ici ça marche parce qu'en fait
c'est par 10 secondes là il compte par
les seconds pressée par papac par
craquer de 10 d'accord qu'il va remettre
le temps un jour regarder elle soit
quand ça oui c'est ça t3 37 d'accord
c'est bien c'est d'accord faut qu'au
regard de la position un petit peu ça va
très vite talent en événements dans le
dernier des partages
décidément c'est un match extrêmement
dans la salle être une partie au couteau
et recomposées jeu un petit rock tu fais
grand roque je rappelle que rob edwards
voyez habitude de +1 4 minutes contre
trois en fait cinq minutes contre quatre
au départ et l'obligation par contre de
gagner donc hélas tout de suite une
partie de chasseurs chasseur blanc quant
aux chasseurs noir les recomposer les
parties aiguilles et d'ailleurs
g4 et l'attaquent de pions
caractéristiques des recomposée façon il
faut qu'ils gagnent romaine doivent donc
là il n'a pas le choix faut gagner
il n 8 de plus mais faut qu'ils gardent
cet avantage il faut pas surtout pas pas
qu'il quittait ses pistes avantages il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils jouent précis
parce qu'il fait aussi gagner otaries
minutes c'est important et bien sûr
monsieur gagné autant surtout mbits
centrale il est très fort en face aux
rouge et noir l'habitude de jouer sur
internet qu'on visite à l'heure même des
parties de son âme dauchy va essayer de
simplifier au maximum la position des
parties de minutes par joueur
il al'habitude de 5,6 mom la position
pour qu'ils aient une position pas trop
difficile à calculer
oui mais c'est pas sûr que ce soit la
bonne tactique il ya ici c'est difficile
à dire ce qu'il faut faire parce que
parce que même si c'est simple si ça
dure longtemps et qu' il peut y avoir
des subtiles voilà attention à la
couleur
alors attention la loisne assouad à mach
4 matches 4 suivies d'oedèmes proches
sept matches oui
protégé par la tour et puis le plancher
le pion j'ai donc il fallait vite faire
une petite fenêtre avec m6 sinon le pion
g5 allait peser sur la position
donc il joue des matches 4 matches 4 1
voilà j'ai 6 mai c'est la dame c7 qui
protège le pion donc sur dame prend
évidemment on reprendrait tout reprendre
apprend vers une pièce une tour la
grande cape town qui veut ouvrir
absolument des lignes sur le roi dont il
est sûr de rien et surtout il veut
affaiblir le pion au 6e oui et récupérer
la cale décès venir avec le cavalier
alors pas tout de suite il va d'abord
revenir effectivement il revient à f2
parce que sinon dans l'âme il a joué g5
pour chasser la dame
kevin tour ensuite mais non il n'y a pas
de tour donc ça va très vite leurs
intentions étaient là tu as ça y est la
case et aux avantages blanc son remède
war est en passe de créer la grosse
surprise de ce premier tour
vraiment vraiment un grand grand match
de romain edouard wii va essayer de
soulager la position avec les charges du
cavalier mais elle a refusé il obtient
une meilleure case ça y est
ça y est dans la gamme et qualité
fourchette de tous les côtés mais non on
peut jouer encore poussé 8 le guen
l'égalité qui ce qui se profile à
l'horizon c'est 8 est possible d'enrayer
la chute il lâcha qualité faille et
lâche la qualité à chaque année ils
lâchent la qualité avantages comme les
doigts redon qui est en passe de tenir
le pari du blitz mort subite avec les
blancs il ya trois minutes devinrent
garder contre une minute 57 à peine
maintenant pour hicham pour les chalets
avoir une qualité de service ça fait
presque une minute trente d'avancé en
plus énormes et en plus il a la qualité
en plus il prend son temps il est obligé
d'apprendre tout de suite les poètes
encore deux tours emprise la paix c'est
d'améliorer quelque 100 positions il
peut bien sûr améliorer sa position
voilà il prend son temps voilà ce qu'il
fait il bien trois cdc de prendre la
tour des huit sur des saints comprend le
fouet sur lyon prend on paiera donc
voilà c'est l'elysée de 6 des 5 voilà
donc il faudra jouer des saints qui le
temps le hca traité rimer ouverture de
ligne 1 c'est horrible toujours le
l'avantagé clairement très clairement
dans les mains de romain edouard alors
qu'elle et dessins qui charment tente en
oeuvre auraient peut-être veut mettre
son cavalier en f4 oui voilà la voie la
cour g3 nerfs très bizarre souk où il va
il va ouvrir la colonne h1n1 oui bien
sûr bien sûr qu'il va prendre un g5
il prend d'abord la qualité sur la
qualité puis prend d'un v6 alors
attention qu'est-ce qui se passe
17 ça fait 7 il fallait défendre la télé
fallait faire le tour des huit tours c3
menace une nouvelle fois il a oublié
il a oublié donc il faut me revient dans
la partie mais il redonne et il a
redonné la qualité de la qualité donc
ouais mais là il est 7e je pense qu'il
est une 7e qui va faire mal
après damas est sur les cépages et il va
falloir être prudent la dame à cette
menace matoto en 2 minutes 30 18 hicham
est un peu revenu dans la partie des
masses est là
non et oui la toque jeu 5 oui parce qu'à
défaut à vii sur damas est qui et qui
défendent des fils comment il pourrait
faire à jouer 6 à m6 bien sûr j'essaie
non menacées dam des trois tours g7 est
une rumeur oui oui vous êtes et être une
vraie menace
dommage trois menaces ça y est ça y est
on va plus pouvoir des formes sera plus
pouvoir défendre hui avec 8
attention cavalli peut-être des deux oui
le cavalier peut venir des deux alors
voilà c'est ça il le fait mais il va y
avoir des cinq pour empêcher de venir le
cavalier peut-être devenir en 4 je sais
pas il va y avoir travaillé pareil sort
des cinq cavaliers et cavalières 3 en f1
ilham aliev trois attaques à la taxe
cinq attaques à cinq
oui menace cabaye prend le sec et le
foot c'est de bouger il est mal et
hicham est en passe de perdre qui
protège champions au terme d'un match de
superbes ont l'âme il est très très fort
romain doit en partie et qui avalise
sodam des six il y aura dame 36 et dames
chez sai thein win menace donc attention
lolo
3-3 pas mal de 3 attention 3 il veut
jouer il est très fort mais doit en
partie rapide une minute 54 entre trente
et une secondes on peut dire que romain
edouard est en passe d'éliminer hicham
attention à ces pierres ça serait
vraiment la grande grande surprise de
cette journée extraordinaire on va
edouard champion d'europe cadets et oui
c'est pas tant qu'il est là ce soir
romain edouard champion d'europe cadet
invité sur ce grand prix et celle de
bordeaux b décidément mois il va
peut-être rendre là surtout reprend f7
peut-être il veut sacrifier dans quoi
elle celle qui va peut-être jouer dame
30 ans prend une assurance cavale
irlandais de u2 bien sûr monasterio de
c'est pour ça qu'il ne peut pas jouer
tours fra n 7 et la jouer à thème au
hajj ou p3 il joue b3 il se fait une
petite île qui te porte de sortie
un tranquille pour mettre le roi à
l'abri des échecs et mat
c'est horrible ce qui est roi il avait
jamais là il avait une faiblesse de la
première rangée hicham hamdouchi il est
très mal autant ils risquent 12 secondes
ça y est la norme ça me fait trop mal à
saillé chat mais ça fait trop mal
là il suffit de jouer ont secoué il
tombe donc ouais non il peut pas il
pourra pas tenir
sûrement ce qui va je pense qu'il
devrait pouvoir les jouer les antiennes
pouces il va prendre des airs gardes
côtiers de grandpuits va prendre 5 avec
le pion bien sûr il va prendre un chèque
avec le pion n'y a rien il on peut rien
faire avec les noirs on est complètement
ficelé vaut la salle d'un des six
voilà alors il va y avoir la prise à 9
cette dame g3 tout simplement
et puisqu'il à la prise à 9,7 peut-être
un atout tant mieux oui or ici gens qui
souffrent ici fiq choix c'est ça mais
qu'est ce qui se passe là oh là là
qu'avec des 3 il fait juste que je vous
ai des coûts et jeux d'éveil pour le
faire tomber oui je le veux le faire
tomber en fait il ya sept secondes à
hicham
je pense qu'il va gagner autant elle n'a
pas vu le pion le pion au nom il le
prend même pas
il jouit là où mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe échec
j'ai reçu une seconde il va arriver à
gagner en géant c'est terminé et
gagnotte et gagne autant là bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien romain et doit remporter son pari
il a réussi à terrasser hicham hamdouchi
bravo félicitations
[Musique]
matches extraordinaires comme vous
l'avez vu vraiment au bout du suspense
dans cette partie alors ça c'est le
blitz
deux parties décisives alors on disait
aux commentaires prêtre romain que tu es
tu es habitué de ces de ces matches je
vais mettre juste là tu es habitué de
ces matches comme ça de partie très
rapide que tu joue beaucoup sur internet
et est ce que tu as pas justement jouer
l'expérience ici et tu as essayé de
faire tomber hicham plutôt que de la
gagner jamais le dernier en gamme et
donc j'ai joué j'ai eu des noirs ça
s'était bien passé mais finalement à
cause du temps j'avais perdu donc j'ai
décidé de prendre mes blanc parce que
pensent que l'or vienne mais non c'est
ce que j'appelle l'arc a dénoncé la mort
subite et je sais pas quel est le bon
c'est el harga maison ce réflexe
l'accord est mort subite alors hicham
c'était un mauvais match fantastique je
pense que ça a été très très chaud et
sur la fin donc en fait cessé
bon visiblement c'est le temps qui
manque pour finir cette partie de moi
on voit bien ses talents de dj gp paul
entrants
la filière
demain
[Musique]
merci chaîne hbo vainqueur emploi un peu
à peu goût à tout moment voilà donc la
edward qualifié pour les demi-finales
demain dans ceux de ce grand prix des
chèques
eh bien nous allons assister après dans
quelques lieux donc à au dernier quart
de finale de ce grand prix je vous
remercie d'avoir assisté à ce match qui
a duré presque delà de ce qui est et ce
qui était prévu mais qui était vraiment
je crois un très très grand spectacle
merci à tous d'avoir assisté donc je
vous demandait de vider la salle
et puis on va essayer de démarrer le
match par contre pas dans pas trop
longtemps
[Musique]